we have more leaked photos from the set
of the Eternals and today we get a look
at a character that everybody has been
wondering about and waiting to see for a
very long time Jimmy Chan as ser Z we
got a look at Angelina Jolie's character
Athena a couple of weeks ago and now we
have new set photos and these new set
photos actually reveal a lot of details
about the plot of the Eternals so let's
break it all down quick reminder if
you'd like a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 be sure to subscribe to my
channel like the video and leave a
comment as well so unfortunately due to
copyrights I can't show the photos but
they are in the link in the description
down below so pull them up while I break
it down so this is our first look at
Jimmy Chan as ser Z now says he is quite
arguably one of the most known eternals
she's been an Avenger before and she has
a relationship with Black Knight who of
course is going to be played by Kit
Harington in the movie and like I said
this is our first look at her in these
photos but what is really interesting
about these photos is that they are in
present-day the leaked eternal set
photos that we got a couple of weeks ago
of Angelina Jolie's character thena
were set in ancient times so we have two
different set photos from two different
periods in time now it is confirmed that
the Eternals is going to take place
thousands of years in the past and it's
also said that we're going to revisit
the history of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in the Eternals movie and this
makes perfect sense because the Eternals
are essentially immortal they can't die
due to old age sickness or disease their
characters who have been around for
thousands and thousands of years and it
seems like we're going to get a good
history lesson of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in the Eternals because again
these set photos of Jimmy Chan as Cersei
are in present day so this means we
officially have confirmation of two
different scenes and two different time
errors in the Eternals these set photos
of Jimmy Chan as Susy confirmed that we
will have seen set in present day and
Angelina Jolie set photos of her as
thena confirmed that we will have scenes
that take place in ancient times
so the Eternals really is going to be an
exciting movie we're really going to
learn about the history of the MCU in
this film and as we get more and more
leaks set photos things are just getting
more exciting for the movie
unfortunately the movie is still a bit
away so it's going to be a while until
we get a teaser trailer or
anything else official about the movie
but check out these leaked set photos in
the link down below and let me know what
you think about them and let me know how
excited you are to see the Eternals once
it finally comes out be sure to comment
down below subscribe and leave a like on
the video so you can enter my giveaway
and stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU also follow me on
twitter and click the link in the
description down below for your chance
to win a Nintendo switch as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof